Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW. Unsere kleine Welt, die vierzigste Ausgabe, mein Name ist Tim Püttler und ja, ich weiß, derzeit geht es hier in.
Schneller folgelos, weil ich mal einen kleinen Rundumschlag machen wollte und mal ein paar andere Felder.
Klappern wollte rund um tja die Corona-Krise, die jetzt so ein bisschen wieder vermehrt vor der Tür steht.
Vielleicht auch schon in der eigenen Wohnung, passt auf euch auf.
Ähm heute soll's mal im Fokus ein wenig mehr noch als sonst um die Corona Warn-App und die ganzen digitalen Infrastrukturen gehen
versuchen uns durch diese Krise irgendwie sicherer zu bringen und dazu gibt's heute mal jemand neues hier im Kanal, nämlich den Henning, Henning Tillmann, hallo Henning.
Hallo Tim, grüß dich.
Herring, du bist ja nun auch ein äh lebhafter Begleiter dieser Korona Warn-App Entwicklung.
Die ganze Zeit schon. Ähm erzähl doch mal so ein bisschen was, was eigentlich so dein Hintergrund ist und warum du dich damit äh so beschäftigst.
Ja, also erst einmal ähm ich bin äh Diplom-Informatiker und selbstständiger Softwareentwickler und da ist man natürlich dann schon von Hause aus quasi interessiert an.
Technischen Entwicklungen, die so stattfinden und ich bin gleichzeitig auch Co-Vorsitzender von D vierundsechzig Zentrum für digitalen Fortschritt, das ist ein gemeinnütziger Verein, der sich dafür einsetzt, ähm, sage ich mal, die digitale Transformation positiv zu gestalten.
Also mit ein bisschen Zuversicht in die Zukunft zu gucken, was nicht Naivität heißen soll, ähm aber eben bestimmte Prozesse ähm ja in die richtigen Bahnen vielleicht zu lenken auf politischer Ebene und sich dafür
einzusetzen. Ähm und aus diesen beiden Sachen äh speist dann sich generell mein Interesse für.
Digitalpolitische Veränderung und die Corona Warnapp ist ja eigentlich ein genau gutes Beispiel für das Zusammenkommen von Technologie, aber eben auch gesellschaftlichen Fragen. Ähm äh da sieht's man halt sehr zugespitzt, nämlich in der Frage, wie können wir mit einer.
App, äh, die, äh, die, die Pandemie bekämpfen, können wir das überhaupt und ähm, ich hab das dann schon Ende März, Anfang April, als die Themen
zum ersten Mal so hoch kamen, kann eine App helfen, äh schon relativ intensiv ähm beobachtet.
Und ähm na ja, da gab's ja nun ganz unterschiedliche Diskussionen. Da ging's ja erst mal darum, na ja, wir brauchen so eine äh ähm eine App, die die auch ähm Quarantäne ähm,
Pflichteinhaltung kontrollieren kann. Wir müssen schauen, wie können wir es überhaupt angehen, dann wurden verschiedene Modelle bei dem Tracing diskutiert, Zentralversus, dezentral.
Und das waren alles so Sachen, die.
Dann vom Interesse ja getriggert haben und wir haben dann als D vierundsechzig unter anderem mit dem CC äh und noch anderen äh Load ähm und anderen Vereinen ähm ja auch einen Brief geschrieben an
das Bundeskanzleramt und dem Bundesgesundheitsminister haben uns sehr stark gegen
damals diskutierten zentralen Ansatz der Chrona App ausgesprochen. Ja und seitdem ist dann mein Interesse auch natürlich da, was dann die Chorona Warnapp selbst betrifft und wie sie sich in den letzten.
Wochen und Monaten entwickelt hat oder eben auch nicht entwickelt.
Ja dieser Brief hat ja dann einen durchschlagenden Erfolg gehabt so, es hat ja dann nicht mehr lange gedauert, bis äh Deutschland dann äh gewechselt ist auf diesen dezentralen Ansatz, der ja glaube ich so.
So eine breite Unterstützung hatte in der digitalen Welt, dass einfach in dieser äh Drucksituation, in der sich die Politik damals äh befand,
das im Nachhinein für mich recht schlüssig war, dass sie zu diesem zu dieser Einschätzung gekommen sind, auch wenn's natürlich Gegenbeispiele gibt. So ist ja zum Beispiel Frankreich bis heute noch nicht auf diesem Weg äh eingeschwenkt.
Wollen Sie aber, also zumindest, wo haben Sie jetzt festgestellt, dass die aktuelle App nicht funktioniert.
Und ich hab da jetzt vor ein paar Tagen Bericht gelesen dass sie jetzt die App neu machen wollen aber zu den genauen Print, also,
kann mir nur vorstellen, dass es jetzt auf den dezentralen Ansatz bringen werden mit dem Google Apple Framor.
Ähm weil ähm na ja, sie funktioniert halt einfach nicht in Frankreich und das waren vor allem auch immer so ein Grund, den den wir ja auch angeführt haben. Es waren ja nicht nur die Datenschutzgründe, äh die natürlich äh auch sehr wichtig sind.
Bei dem zentralen Ansatz weswegen das kritisch ist, sondern eben auch die praktikablen Gründe. Es funktioniert einfach nicht.
Wenn man's nicht auf Betriebssystemebene vernünftig implementiert hat. Und jetzt kann man natürlich kritisch auf Google und Apple zugehen und sagen, hey, ihr schreibt nur einen Weg vor, den man gehen kann.
Meine Diskussion könnte man führen, aber ähm jetzt kann man aus unserer Datenschutzsicht auch sagen, Gott sei Dank haben sie sich für den richtigen Ansatz entschieden. Äh Peru und Google, aber ohne eben die beiden im Boot zu haben, wird's halt schwierig.
Und was man halt an in der Entscheidung im April schon auch sagen kann als dann die Bundesregierung zum Glück auch umgeschwenkt ist. Ähm, dass es dann natürlich sehr sehr schnell ging. Also ich glaube am in der Nacht von Freitag auf Samstag.
Ist dann so ein bisschen die Entscheidung gefallen äh bei äh ähm beim Kanzleramt und Gesundheitsminister und am Montag stand irgendwie fest.
Dass es Telekom und SAP werden sollen, die das dann auch umsetzen. Das ging dann schon sehr sehr schnell äh und ähm na ja.
Allerdings. Da hat man schon den Eindruck gehabt, dass halt mehrere äh Gespräche parallel geführt wurden.
Ja und äh was man da also man kann ja.
Also erstmal ist es ja gut, dass es sich für diese Richtung entschieden haben. Das ist ja klar. Die Frage ist, wie geht man dann daran und ähm
man das Open Songs gemacht hat, dass man das auch mit einer sehr großen Transparenz gemacht hat. Das war gut. Also äh man kannte ja bei Gitter.
Fast alles äh nachschlagen oder nicht nur fast alles, sondern man kann alles nachschlagen. Ähm es wurde auch nochmal in PDFs.
Kommentiert, was da für ein Ansatz ist, aber eben dieser Spirit zu sagen, na ja, wir holen auch wirklich mehr Open Source.
Von von extern rein. Also wir wir wollen auch äh.
Weitere Codeideen von anderen Leuten einbinden. Das wurde ja nicht so wirklich gemacht. Also es gab äh schon sicherlich äh Bugs auf die hingewiesen worden sind und auf Verbesserungsvorschläge in diesem Fall, aber eine wirkliche.
Idee, das zu modularisieren zum Beispiel oder äh äh Sachen auszulagern und einzubinden. Das ist nicht, äh hat nicht stattgefunden, vor allem wäre eben auch nicht in den letzten ähm Wochen und Monaten und da kann man dann natürlich sagen, okay, da hat man dann sieht man vielleicht doch.
Dass es was ausmacht, wenn man es zwei großen Unternehmen gibt, anstatt dass man's vielleicht wirklich neu denkt und über.
Jetzt nicht mehr Start-ups sagen, weil das einfach so abgedroschen klingt, aber einen neuen Weg zu gehen.
Da hat man sich dann eher für den klassischen Ansatz entschieden mit einer Open Swash Komponente, die der Transparent eher gut tut, aber tatsächlich eher nur der Transparenz.
Nicht der Zusammenarbeit, die eben bei Open Source ja auch eine Rolle spielt.
Ja, da weiß ich, was du meinst, ist natürlich so, wenn wenn man Open Source Projekte kennt, ähm.
So ohne weiteres entwickelt sich natürlich das auch bei klassischen Konstellationen auch nicht so ohne Weiteres. Also bis man da wirklich eine Zusammenarbeit bekommt, braucht's natürlich auch eine gewachs,
Community, brauchst viele Leute mit Einblick, auch Leute, die bereit sind, ihre Zeit auch außerhalb einer Bezahlung intensiv wirklich äh in die Verfolgung eines solchen Projektes zu
investieren und das ist natürlich selten gegeben und ich glaub das ist auch hier.
Eher so ein Traum, also dass dass man jetzt so ohne Weiteres da so eine Community aus dem Nichts rausschütteln kann, die sich dann auf einem brauchbaren Level mit einbringt. Das ist dann doch schon ein bisschen viel verlangt, finde ich für diese kurze Zeit.
Ja und nein, du hast natürlich Recht, was die Organisation betrifft, ähm, ist das sicherlich nicht so einfach, aber
gab schon auch Initiativen, die außerhalb ähm der der sage ich mal SAP Telekom Welt entstanden sind. Also ich verweise zum Beispiel auf den Viversus Virus Hackeston, wo es Initiativen gab auch für ein Tracing.
Und ähm da wurde aber dann auch seitens äh äh
der Veranstalterinnen und Veranstalter gesagt, aber eben auch der Bundesregierung, na ja, wir entwickeln jetzt hier äh eigentlich eine zentrale Lösung, lass das mal lieber sein und die sind dann relativ früh aus diesem Prozess, äh der.
Unterstützung innerhalb des Hackers und rausgekommen. Also rausgeflogen.
Und da halte man natürlich von Anfang an sagen können, hey cool ähm wir haben jetzt zwar hier, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was der Zahl, die Horizont war, ich glaube, das war noch vor der Entscheidung ähm für Telekom SAP, äh der Vivesus Virus Hackerson, aber man hätte natürlich sagen können, hey, wir halten uns das erstmal offen.
Mach das mal und dann gucken wir mal, dass wir das irgendwie modularisiert irgendwie hinbekommen. Also ich gebe dir Recht, es ist tatsächlich manchmal auch viel Illusion dabei, aber wenn man es denn will.
Würde es glaube ich auch gehen.
Ja. Also es ist glaube ich ein bisschen müßig jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt, da äh das jetzt sozusagen als als ein Kernproblem herauszustellen. Das ist sicherlich ein Aspekt über den man diskutieren kann, den man anstreben kann. Viel hängt ein bisschen meiner Auffassung nach, auch davon ab
Wie ist dieses Team jetzt bei SAP? Also ist ja, sagen wir mal, was jetzt diesen eigentlichen Appteil betrifft, ist ja vor allem.
Das Team was von SAP repräsentiert wird, was hier aktiv ist, während Telekom sicher mehr um Infrastrukturlaboranbindungen und so weiter kümmert, was ja nochmal so ein zweiter Teil ist, den man vielleicht auch nochmal betrachten sollten und ähm
Die war ja nun durchaus engagiert, auch äh unterwegs. Die Frage ist natürlich, ist jetzt auch die Finanzierung und die Motivation seitens der Bundesregierung so ausgerichtet, diese Motivation, diese Gruppe auch beisammen zu halten. Wenn
bleiben die selben Leute im Team, werden die da kontinuierlich beschäftigt. Also, dass die sozusagen auch zusammenstehen und nicht eben so, okay, jetzt ist die Hauptarbeit es getan
Jetzt nehmen wir die Leute da wieder raus, führen die wieder in andere Gruppen zu und entziehen sozusagen diesen Gedankenprozess raus. Ich glaube, das, was du auch meinst, mit diesen Start-up-Gedanken ist ja mehr so dieses, man hat dann so ein Team, was sich auch über einen längeren Zeitraum.
So einer Entwicklung ähm identifiziert.
Immer da drin mental verhaftet ist, weiter drüber nachdenkt, selber auch sieht, wo die Limitierung und die neuen Herausforderungen sind und das dann auch immer wieder sofort in den Entwickl
Prozess einbringt. Versus eines Modells
wo man dann so ich sag mal jetzt ein bisschen überzogen für 'ne kurze Zeit so die Söldner am Start hat, die das dann vielleicht auch ordentlich machen, aber dann eben sofort wieder mental woanders abgekippt werden und man entzieht sozusagen an der Stelle der Entwicklung auch so ein bisschen diesen diesen Hirnsaft.
Genau, genau, ähm also.
Damit ich nicht falsch gestanden werde, ich äh will die Corona Warneb an ihrer Grundfunktionalität gar nicht schlecht reden. Ich glaube, da hat man auch solide Arbeit ja gemacht. Äh wenn man jetzt mal vielleicht äh die kommunikativen Probleme.
Abzieht, dies dann auch über den Sommer auch gab, aber äh sage ich mal, von der Entwicklung ist das alles okay. Ähm die Frage ist tatsächlich, der Spirit, mit dem man darangehen will. Ähm du hast es gerade beschrieben, es ist eher der Spirit, dass man das jetzt mal eben entwickelt und dann.
Verabschieden wir uns auch geistig so ein bisschen davon oder ist es eher so ein Spül, dass man das ähm weiterdenkt, dass man eine Roadmap veröffentlicht, dass man sagt, wo will man hin? Was sind kurz
sind langfristige Ziele. Und das hat man sowohl
wieder bei der Telekom SAP als auch bei den Auftraggebern, sprich RKI und dann eben ja auch die Bundesregierung nicht gesehen. Da kann man Telekom SAP jetzt gar nicht so unbedingt einen Vorwurf machen, weil.
Kurs wird ja vom Auftraggeber vorgegeben und das ist ja in diesem Fall ähm Bundesregierung, beziehungsweise ähm Robert Koch Institut.
Ja und ich denke an der Stelle merkt man natürlich schon noch, dass sie eben mit diesem Entwicklungsmodell einfach
ja, dass dass für sie, wie man so schön sagt, Neuland äh ist, ja und ähm dass sie noch gar nicht so richtig verstanden haben, was sie sich da eigentlich für Vorschusslohbeeren äh eingetreten haben, die die natürlich auch welten können, wenn man sich nicht drum kümmert.
Ja äh ich fand, ich fand das ja so so exemplarisch diese Pressekonferenz, die da im Juni stattgefunden hat, wo ähm ich glaube äh unter Pandemiebedingungen sehr, sehr viele Leute auf dem Podium saßen
und ich glaube vier vier Ministerinnen und Minister, Staatssekretärin, Telekom-Chef, RKI-Chef, SAP-Chef. Ähm, so und.
Ist ja schön und da du hast es ja gerade gehört, das ist ein Vorschusslobbeen, die auch zurecht gegeben worden sind, weil man vieles auch richtig gemacht hat, aber ich habe das Gefühl gehabt, dass.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt ist diese Pressekonferenz war, danach war dann ein Häkchen drunter. Okay, haben wir's ja jetzt rausgemacht. Okay, gut, dann lassen wir das mal sein. Und das ist halt eben schade.
Weil das ist halt dann eben ja nicht diese Pandemie oder auch die Corona Warnep, verstehe ich als kontinuierlichen Prozess und der Weg ist das Ziel,
nicht so unter dem Motto, wir haben jetzt 'ne App, die auch grundsätzlich funktioniert und dann, ja gut, dann brauchen wir nicht weiter drüber nachdenken, das ist halt schade.
Schauen wir da vielleicht mal kurz auf den Teil der vor allem durch die Telekom repräsentiert wird, weil da ist ja nun auch die Ausbeute nicht ganz so toll, ne? Also diese Anbindung der Labore, um die App äh in die Lage zu versetzen
Test,
mehr oder weniger schnell äh gemeldet zu bekommen, sodass man, wenn man positiv ist, dass auch sofort dann in den Pool geben kann. Das hat ja so versprochen, sehr kurze Turnaround-Zeiten zu realisieren. Die Realität ist, dass man einfach an sehr vielen Stellen, wo man einen Test macht,
diesen passenden QR-Code, der das alles abkürzt, so nicht erhält. Und es gibt auch keinerlei wirkliche Transparenz darüber.
Wer das jetzt macht, wer das wann, wie macht, warum's noch nicht gemacht wurde, woran's eigentlich hängt, ähm dass es irgendwie für mich extrem unübersichtlich.
Wie siehst du das.
Ja, äh, sehe ich ähnlich, ich muss aber ehrlicherweise zusagen, ich bin jetzt nicht der absolute Experte, was diese Laborverknüpfungen betrifft. Ähm es ist aber tatsächlich so, dass in vielen Fällen auch überhaupt nicht wirklich auf die Chorona-Warn-App hingewiesen wird. Ähm das war zum Beispiel auch so bei den
Bei den Teststationen, das kenne ich aus mehreren Fällen, äh äh die mir das berichtet haben, die sich zum aus als Reiserückkehrer, aus äh Österreich, nach Bayern durchgefahren sind oder so weiter, wo es gar keine noch nicht mal einen Hinweis äh gab äh auf.
Runa Warneb, hinzu kommen ja eben, wie du's gerade beschrieben hast, dass
man eben nicht mit einfach QR-Code das einscannen, sondern kann, sondern einfach wirklich sehr manuell in vielen Fällen noch vorgehen muss. Auch in Berlin zum Beispiel ähm in bei den vielen vielen Laboren, dass man halt ähm dann die Hotline anrufen muss.
Wobei es da ja interessanterweise wurde bei der hundert Tage Corona Presse äh Corona war in der Pressekonferenz ja gesagt, dass es
daran angeblich gar nicht scheitern soll, dass viele Leute so Hotline ja auch anrufen würden. Ähm.
Aber klar, das ist natürlich kein Prozess, der der intuitiv äh unbedingt ist und einfach geht und der vor allem, wenn man Datenschutzfragen stellt, da eben dieses kleine Nadelöhr hat, wo es
Tatsächlich für einen Moment schwieriger wird, ähm aber ähm ja.
Dass das bis jetzt äh was haben wir Juni, jetzt haben wir Oktober äh noch nicht wirklich geklappt hat oder in vielen Fällen nicht geklappt hat, zeigt irgendwie das Grundproblem, was es ja in vielen Ebenen der digitalen Transformation in der Bundesrepublik noch gibt
ne? Also wenn viele Sachen per Fax noch verschickt werden, ist das natürlich eine Sache, die jetzt super sichtbar wird
aber die ja jetzt auch nicht zum ersten Mal kritisiert wird, nur man hat das vielleicht vor eins, zwei, drei Jahren nicht so wirklich dann ernst genommen. Na, glaubt man, ja, wir kommen ja, wir sind jetzt die letzten dreißig Jahre gut vorangekommen, warum sollen wir das denn ändern.
Ja ähnlich ist es ja mit dem ganzen Datenmaterial vom äh RKI da scheint der Lernprozess auch einfach zu langsam.
Zu finden. Es ist einer da, aber ja es geht äh es kann uns ja auch nicht schnell genug äh gehen. Hm
wo wir jetzt die ganzen Akteure kurz nochmal beleuchten, sollten wir vielleicht auch nochmal auf die Rolle von Apple und Google eingehen
Das ist ja auch am Anfang ein ziemlicher Fight gewesen, wo auf der einen Seite die Unternehmen natürlich ganz klar als Gate-Keeper im Raum standen, die äh einiges ermöglichen können, aber die auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch immer wieder äh dieses Problem hatten, dass sie jetzt.
Ohnehin in der Öffentlichkeit immer mit diesem Vorwurf des Datensammelns und Überwachens konfrontiert sind und jetzt auf einmal äh diese neueartige Idee aufkam.
Denkst du, dass sie das gut gemanagt haben? Und da noch genug tun.
Also prinzipiell würde ich sagen ja ähm ich glaube, dass man natürlich auch äh dieser pauschal Vorwurf Apple und Google machen das ja alles vor allem wegen Daten sammeln, würde ich zum Beispiel bei Apple halt eben nicht sehen. Die haben einfach ein völlig anderes Geschäftsmodell
und da ist es ja exibizit ja nicht so, ist klar, sagen wir sie natürlich auch Daten verwenden, aber wenn vielen Sachen
auch äh Verfahren äh eben um nicht einen direkten Personenbezug herzustellen, aber das ist natürlich nochmal ein anderes Thema. Dafür ähm Privacy und so weiter, aber ähm,
Das ist natürlich nochmal unterschiedliche Geschäftsmodelle bei den beiden da. Aber klar ähm äh Daten sammeln und so weiter wird gerne genannt und man kann schon sagen, dass dieser Ansatz den ja Apple und Google jetzt mit dem Exposé Notification Framework, das ist quasi der
Das Fundament eben der Corona Warn-App oder auch anderer ähm Tracing Apps, die auf diesem System basieren äh dass das eigentlich aus vielen.
Perspektiven sehr viel Gutes gemacht wurde. Man hat auch zwar ein bisschen spät dann auch den kompletten äh den Quellcode äh nochmal dazu auch.
Öffentlich gemacht. Man hat das recht gut dokumentiert schon von Anfang an ab April und ich meine sie hätten es ja auch nicht tun müssen, das kann man ja auch sagen, ne? Also ähm.
Das ist ein
die beiden Betriebssystemhersteller haben natürlich eine gewisse Verantwortung auch, diese, der sie sich hier nicht entziehen können. Ich finde, dass sie da auch äh in dem Bezug ganz gut geliefert haben
Und ähm da wird man auch nochmal so ein bisschen deutlich, äh, wer eigentlich die Hauptarbeit dieser ganzen Tracing Apps eben macht und das ist tatsächlich eben nicht.
Die nationalen Anbieter
sondern ähm die Betriebssystemhersteller und deswegen sieht man auch im Vergleich zu anderen äh äh Tracing Apps, die ja zum Beispiel auf diesem zentralen Ansatz basieren oder eben auch die Fonds
der Veröffentlichung des Frameworks gearbeitet haben, dass sie nicht wirklich funktioniert haben, weil du brauchst halt die Betriebssysteme
um vernünftig arbeiten zu können bei dem Austausch von Bluetooth Schlüsseln und ohne klappt's dann doch eher unzuverlässig.
Das zeigt sich ja auch ganz äh deutlich jetzt in so einer neuen Entwicklung, die meiner Meinung nach noch vollkommen unter äh beleuchtet äh zu sein scheint.
Es ist ja mit den neuesten Releases dieser Exposa-Notification Frameworks jetzt ja im Prinzip wirklich auch ohne diese App, die ja eigentlich auch gar nicht so viel tut, ja? Äh
an diesem Ganzen Verteilsystem teilzunehmen. Sprich, wenn jetzt ein Land ähm an diesem Datenaustausch.
Und und dieser Warnmöglichkeit teilnehmen möchte, bräuchten Sie so 'ne
Entwicklung überhaupt nicht anzustoßen, sondern sie müssen eigentlich im Prinzip nur so einen Server von Google, den es so als ready to Run äh als Open Source gibt
den müssen sie einfach nur betreiben und sagen, okay, das ist jetzt hier unser offizieller Server, wir beglaubigen das und äh
stellen die entsprechenden Zertifikate aus und dann könnte er im Prinzip jedes Land sofort mehr oder weniger für null kosten mitmachen.
Also abgesehen jetzt von Datenmengen und so weiter, was ja eher zu vernachlässigen ist. Hast du das irgendwie gesehen, dass das schon irgendein Land auch äh zum Einsatz bringen möchte.
Das da bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher, man muss also das ist mir jetzt direkt nicht bekannt, müsste ich recherchieren, aber die Sache ist ja die, dass es zum Beispiel in den USA.
Keine Bundes also US-Arbeit, Corona Tracing App gibt, sondern es ist eine Frage der Bundesstaaten ist.
Für diese Bundesstaaten soll's vor allem eben auch diesen Ansatz geben, aber natürlich auch vielleicht für.
Länder der Welt, die sich das nicht leisten können wollen oder nicht die Kompetenzen zeigt, was auch immer haben. Ähm aber es unterstreicht ja nochmal eben, wie viel Arbeit eigentlich tatsächlich sowieso schon bei Apple und Google vorher lag oder beziehungsweise bei diesem Framework.
Wie viel eigentlich dann noch die nationalen Apps gemacht haben. Und das ist ja auch dann, wo man dann so fragen kann, hm,
sind dann diese zwanzig Millionen Entwicklungskosten in Deutschland plus äh äh weitere äh äh vierzig Millionen äh Wartungs- und äh Instandhaltungskosten äh so ganz gerechtfertigt oder eben nicht
Also man kann das sich wirklich so ein bisschen vorstellen wie ähm.
Wie ein Haus, was gebaut wird, äh das Fundament und die Wände äh haben sowieso das Framework gesetzt. Ähm und was dann die Länder gemacht haben oder was auch die Corona Warnapp dann an sich ist, ist nochmal das Dach und äh der Anstrich der Wende. Ähm
Und diese beiden Schritte würden jetzt sogar Apple und Google teilweise auch noch mit übernehmen. Ähm
das auch immer alles gut ist, kann man auch nochmal diskutieren oder kann man dann auch mal auch nochmal beleuchten aber es setzt nochmal oder zeigt nochmal die Relation, die eigentlich da sind.
Und tatsächlich ist hier so 'ne deutsche Chorona Bahn App im Vergleich zum Beispiel mit der irischen Corona Warnapp nicht so groß unterschiedlich
weil sie eben auf dem gleichen Fundament passieren.
Obwohl sie sich dann im Detail dann doch äh unterscheiden, da kommen wir gleich nochmal drauf, wo wir jetzt gerade bei dieser Internationalisierung äh sind, meine die neueste Entwicklung ist ja jetzt die
dass die äh Corona Warneb zumindest jetzt erstmal mit der irischen und mit der italienischen Infrastruktur zusammengeschaltet wird.
Das wird ja jetzt ermöglicht über ein neues Feature, was vor ein paar Wochen im in den Frameworks veröffentlicht worden ist
und also von Apple und Google veröffentlicht worden ist. Mit dem es jetzt halt ähm einerseits das Telefon halt merkt, ich bin im Ausland und wenn man halt im Ausland ist, dann werden dann auch.
Also würde ich jetzt nach Italien fahren und wäre da äh drei Tage, dann würde halt für diese drei Tage auch der italienische Server befragt werden nach äh entsprechenden Schlüsseln, äh genauso mit äh Irland und äh andersrum, wenn äh ich halt.
Ähm selber mich positiv melde, würde würden dann eben meine Schlüssel äh auf so einen EU-Server quasi verteilt werden, wo alle anderen äh sowieso regelmäßig nachfragen. Und das äh.
Hat länger gedauert, als ich dachte. Ich dachte, es müsste schneller gehen und mir scheint es halt vor allem so eine politische EU-politische, europapolitische Problematik zu sein,
Ähm hast du das irgendwie verfolgt und was denkst du erhält eigentlich die EU davon ab, hier mal auch äh vielleicht mehr äh ans Ruder zu gehen.
Und zu sagen, wir machen das jetzt einfach mal so.
Ja, das ist ein guter Punkt. Äh tatsächlich wäre er auch ein guter Ansatz gewesen, wenn man von vornherein gesagt hätte, man würde vielleicht eine europäische Korona Warnapp herausbringen oder man würde einen Frameworker, also beziehungsweise ein
ein Code äh äh weiß ich nicht, stellt man Open Source und alle anderen Länder passen das noch ein bisschen an und bringen das als eigene App raus, wie auch immer. Also ein gemeinsames Vorgehen. Das Wude meines Wissens auch mal teilweise versucht
im Frühsommer das ranzugehen, aber es gab keine Einigung mit den einzelnen Ländern.
Kann man natürlich auch unterschiedlich argumentieren, wie stark hat ähm die Kommissionspräsidentin, die sich da wohl auch für eingesetzt hat, Ursula von der Leyen.
Wie viel wie viel Durchsetzungskraft hat sie oder wie stark hat sich's überhaupt versucht? Ähm das ist natürlich dann das kann man politisch äh interpretieren.
Aber ähm ja in der Tat ist das natürlich schade, weil ähm das wäre natürlich ein ein Vorzeigeprojek
gewesen, was man hätte auf europäischer Ebene durchführen können, aber es zeigt ja eben auch am Beispiel Frankreich sogar, Deutschland, Frankreich, äh dass es äh da noch nicht mal eine einheitliche Linie gab, weil ja Frankreich eben auch
wir hatten kurz gerade schon mal kurz angesprochen, den zentralen Ansatz ähm verfolgt hat. Ähm der wie gesagt nicht wirklich funktioniert und da ist eine Kompatibilität eben.
Ähm ich will nicht sagen
Komplett unmöglich, aber ähm sehr, sehr, sehr schwierig. Ähm anders als eben bei Deutschland und Italien und warum es da im Endeffekt jetzt so lange gedauert hat, ähm das ist tatsächlich auch für mich eine große Frage, weil
na ja, ich sag auch immer auch so, ähm, es ist jetzt schön, dass wir das haben zu dem Zeitpunkt, aber
Ob jetzt im Winter äh viel Reiseverkehr stattfinden wird, vor allem zwischen, sage ich mal, jetzt Deutschland und Italien
Anders siehst du echt nochmal äh zwischen Deutschland und Frankreich aus, da ist ja auch viel Berufsverkehr der der äh äh nochmal pendelt. Ähm.
Ja ähm ist jetzt schön zu haben, aber natürlich wäre das sinnvoller gewesen schon im August.
Schon zu einer Einigung zu kommen.
Ja und auch nicht nur Einigung zu kommen, sondern auch, äh, dass wir uns da schon hätte lauffähig gehabt, ne? Also ähm wenn man im Juni, Juli ähm das äh soweit auf europäischer Ebene vorangebracht hätte, dass man sagen könnte, okay, ihr müsst euch nur noch andocken
als nationale.
Und wir gehen jetzt hier einen Weg vor und wir machen jetzt, wir machen hier Vorschläge, ähm äh dann ähm wäre das halt eben auch schneller gegangen. Ähm aber das ist auch diese, das ist das, was ich meinte mit diesem Spirit. Ich habe das Gefühl
Am Anfang ist, es ist nicht so wirklich, es wird gemacht, so ein bisschen nach Vorschrift, wir müssen das jetzt auch tun
aber für mich fehlt irgendwie das Feuer. Also ich weiß nicht, ob was ob du weißt, was ich meine, aber für mich fehlt irgendwie so dieser Ansatz, okay, jetzt gehen wir da mal ran und wir wollen das jetzt auch mal äh.
Wir denken jetzt mal schon einen Tag voraus, ja? Ähm und äh äh.
Interessanterweise, wenn dann auch immer gesagt wird, na ja, vielleicht war Apple und Google nicht so schnell und da gab's bestimmte Sachen noch nicht. Ein Grund, warum zum Beispiel Telekom und SAP ja ausgewählt worden sind, war ja der angebliche, die angebliche Augenhöhe.
Apple und Google, ja? Ähm und gerade vielleicht kommen wir dann ja auch nochmal drauf auf diese ganzen Warnmeldungen und Fehlermeldungen und Irritationen, die es über den Sommer gab, habe ich nicht so viel davon gemerkt.
Von dieser Augenhöhe und ähm.
Ist es gut, dass es das jetzt gibt. Äh äh die Zusammenarbeit oder die die der Austausch zwischen Italien, Irland, Deutschland, es kommen noch andere Länder dazu. Ähm ob das jetzt wie viel das jetzt im Endeffekt über den Winter jetzt hilft.
Weiß ich nicht. Also ist natürlich nice to have, aber mehr glaube ich auch nicht, weil so viel Reiseverkehr wird jetzt, glaube ich, in der nächsten Zeit ist auch nicht stattfinden.
Das stimmt allerdings auch wieder.
Jetzt hattest du ja zusammen mit äh Karl Lauterbach auch von der SPD ähm in der Zeit so einen Artikel rausgebracht, wo ihr ein paar Vorschläge gemacht habt, wie sich die App aus eurer Perspektive äh.
Noch so verändern könnte und welche Features man dort denn mal einbauen äh könnte
Die Punkte würde ich ganz gerne nochmal durchgehen. Ich habe das hier mit Pavel äh auch schon mal ähm besprochen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du die Gelegenheit hattest, äh unsere An
Hast du gehört? Ich hoffe es äh war dich zu vernichtend. Ähm war etwas ähm skeptisch, aber vielleicht können wir das ja mal gemeinsam nochmal diskutieren. Ich denke, ihr habt im Wesentlichen so vier Punkte äh gemacht. Es fing an mit.
Mehr Informationen mehr Transparenz äh sehen wollt, da äh gehe ich ja auch voll mit. Ich denke, dass die äh CWA derzeit einem einfach noch zu wenig bietet und für mein Gefühl auch.
Eine Spur.
Zu extrem auf diese ganze Datenschutzdebatte ähm reagiert hat, indem halt auch Informationen, die einem das Google Apple Framework äh bietet, nicht angezeigt werden.
Also ich ganz gut, vielleicht ähm als, als Disclaimer, also ich bin auch Mitglied der SPD, ähm habe aber in der SPD kein Amt und keine Funktion, also ähm daher ist auch, sage ich mal, der Kontakt zu Karl Lauterbach äh äh da. Ähm.
Also D vierundsechzig ist ja auch generell als SPD nah einzustufen, ja? Aber ist nicht wirk.
Ja, na ja, also das da muss ich immer bis.
Da muss ich ja, es ist richtig, es gibt sicherlich viele Mitglieder, äh, die auch ein SPD-Parteibuch haben, in der Tat ist es aber so, dass D vierundsechzig ein gemeinnütziger und dadurch auch unabhängiger Verein ist
und wir haben genauso Mitglieder bei uns, die den Grünen angehören, die den Linken angehören, den Piraten angehören
wir haben sogar vereinzelte FDP und auch CDU-Mitglieder bei uns vereinzelt allerdings wirklich nur.
Und es ist natürlich in der Historie schon so, dass die der Verein auch von SPD Mitgliedern gegründet wurde. Ich bin auch ein Mit
äh der SPD und ja eben auch Co-Vorsitzender von D vierundsechzig, aber ähm wir achten schon sehr, sehr stark dadrauf, dass wir keine Partei äh irgendwie besser beurteilen oder schlechter
Aber es ist natürlich schon richtig, dass es Kontakte gibt, ähm die wir nutzen äh um halt auch irgendwie auf was hinzuweisen.
Aber wir reden genauso mit Grünen und anderen Parteien und ich glaube, dass wir uns eher so als linksprogressiv verstehen würden, ähm und jeder äh
jeder Strömung, Partei oder was auch immer, die sich auch so sieht, äh, mit denen arbeiten wir natürlich auch gern zusammen. Ähm, also das so gleich kurz zur Einordnung. Ähm.
Als kleiner Disclay war, okay.
Ein kleines Thema, aber er war natürlich richtig bin, bin halt auch SPD-Mitglied, da mache ich auch gar keinen Hehl raus. Ähm so, genau zu diesen Vorschlägen, also vielleicht, ähm, diese Vorschläge, die wir da äh aufgeschrieben haben.
Sind vier Beispiele für Erweiterung und das äh soll gar nicht heißen, dass das jetzt äh die besten vier Vorschläge sind und andere sollte es nicht geben. Was.
Grundidee auch dieses Beitrags war.
Nehmen wir oft äh bei der Zeit veröffentlicht haben, war, dass wir äh sagen wollten, hey, es muss sich was tun in der App und das hat ja eben verschiedene äh äh Nebeneffekte auch. Einerseits wird die Funktionalität natürlich erweitert, der App.
Andererseits gibt's natürlich auch wieder so einen passiven Marketingeffekt, also dadurch, dass es mehr Funktionen gibt.
App wieder mehr ins Gespräch, es laden sich vielleicht mehr Leute, die App runter ähm und äh wir haben das jetzt auf vier Sachen begrenzt.
Aber man könnte genauso noch über andere Sachen sprechen, zum Beispiel mehr Informationen der App anzubieten, aber vielleicht können wir da.
Ja danach später sprechen. Zu den einzelnen vier Vorschlägen. Also genau, wir haben äh das so aufgeteilt in den ersten Punkt, mehr Informationen, mehr Transparenz. Äh du hast es gerade schon gesagt, die das das Framework würde eigentlich mehr Informationen anbieten
die werden teilweise aber gar nicht richtig angezeigt. Vor allem und das finde ich zum schwierigsten Punkt ich glaub das sehen die meisten so zumindestens wirklich da immer nur in irritierte Augen. Ist dieser Hinweis
Sie hatten drei Kontakte mit niedrigem Risiko.
Was sagt mir das jetzt? Eigentlich nichts. Also ähm es war ja sogar so, dass als wir den Text geschrieben haben, es in der App noch nicht einmal, also der Text haben wir im August geschrieben, der kam Anfang September.
Ersten September bei der Zeit, aber ähm im August war es noch nicht mal so.
Du irgendwelche Informationen innerhalb der App bekommen hast, was das eigentlich bedeutet mit dem niedrigen Risiko. Ähm.
Und auch jetzt, was sagt mir das? Es sagt mir eigentlich nichts, also wenn man sich die Information anguckt, sagt na ja, sie hatten Kontakt, aber haben sich wahrscheinlich nicht angesteckt, weil sie waren zu weit weg oder sie hatten zu kurz Kontakt. Sie brauchen nichts tun.
Ja gut, aber warum sagt ihr mir das dann? Ja, also das ist halt so so eine Information, die ähm die.
Ja eher verwirrt als dass sie wirklich hilft. Zumindest in diesem in diesem Bezug, wie sie da steht, weil er nämlich auch gar keine Datumsangabe ist. Wenn jetzt zum Beispiel da stehen würde, dass man äh ähm diesen niedrigen Risikenkontakt hatte am.
Samstagabend, wo man vielleicht äh ähm weiß ich nicht, äh auf einer Feier war.
Dann könnte man das zuordnen und könnte dann daraus natürlich auch gewisse gewissen Mehrwert ziehen.
Und sagen oh ja vielleicht da war ich tatsächlich mit ein paar Leuten näher im Gespräch oder es war wirklich eng, es wurde nicht gelüftet
Okay, jetzt gebe ich mich tatsächlich ein bisschen in in äh sage ich mal, achte ich mal ein bisschen mehr auf Symptome oder äh begebe mich in ähm Quarantäne. Ähm.
Oder wenn's zum Beispiel andersrum wäre, dass man sagt OK ich war draußen auf dem Flugfeld hier in Tempelhof
und ich saß da aber nur mit meiner Freundin oder mit meinem Freund auf der auf der Decke okay ich kann das einteilen nee da kann ich mich nicht infiziert haben,
das ist wirklich kein Risiko was da war. Und genau diese Information die fehlt. Also entweder betrag ich das gar nicht an.
Blöd wäre oder ich gebe halt mehr Informationen über diesen Kontakt. Es sieht ja ein bisschen anders aus bei dem erhöhten Risiko.
Da wird ja irgendwie gesagt, dass der irgendwie zwei, drei Tage her ist, ähm aber auch da fehlen natürlich ein genauer Bezug
Und da müsste man mal überlegen, ähm auch wenn ich ein riesiger Freund von Datenschutz ähm und äh äh so bin und wir haben uns ja eben auch für diesen dezentralen Ansatz ausgesprochen.
Aber man muss natürlich auch überlegen, wo ist dann ein Mehrwert auch wirklich äh für den gewarn.
Ohne, dass ich jetzt hier wirklich preisgebe, es war Karl Müller, der dich angesteckt hat. Natürlich kann man auf äh äh Grund des Zeit-und Zeitpunkts irgendwie dann einen Bezug herstellen. Aber wenn ich die Person kenne,
würde ich wahrscheinlich eh übers Gesundheitsamt informiert werden, wenn sie nicht gerade überlastet sind.
Weil ich ihn Kontakt hatte und wenn ich sie nicht kenne und irgendeine Person mir in der Nähe war ja gut dann kann ich trotzdem weiß ich trotzdem nicht wer es war.
Da bin ich, da bin ich komplett bei dir, ich würde sogar noch einen Schritt weitergehen und sagen, man müsste vielleicht und das,
muss man dazu sagen, manche Änderungen, die wir jetzt so diskutieren, sind Änderungen, die könnte man ohne Weiteres in dieser App machen, wie zum Beispiel das Datum nennen. Das ist eine Information, die fällt jetzt schon an, ne? Die Uhrzeit zum Beispiel wird einem nicht gesagt, derzeit vom Fremwork, auch wenn das
technisch vorgesehen ist, kriegt man quasi nur so ein Null-Uhr äh äh genannt, also man kann nicht wirklich auf eine Uhrzeit äh zurückschließen. Wobei ich auch finde, dass das.
Durchaus eine eine interessante Information wäre. Und ich fände es halt auch eine interessante Information, wenn die App in der Lage wäre, mir dann zu sagen, wo denn das war, ja, also quasi, ich meine, ich weiß doch selber, wo ich war. Also äh warum kann sich nicht das Telefon das für mich merken? Andere Apps können sich das ja auch für mich merken, wann ich wo war. Ähm
Also klar ich verste.
Ja, aber da kommt's natürlich dann in eine andere Thematik rein, ne?
Ja, natürlich kommst du in andere Problematiken rein. Aber lassen wir das vielleicht mal mit dieser Location mal außen vor. Grundsätzlich würde man ja sicher wünschen, dass diese äh App mehr wie so ein.
Wie so ein wie soll ich sagen? Ja, wie so ein Geigerzähler äh funktioniert und einem so ein Gefühl dafür äh äh gibt, auch mehr oder wenig weniger in Echtzeit
wie so die Situation ist, wie viel
Kontakte habe ich überhaupt, wie viel andere Apps sehe ich überhaupt mal ganz unabhängig davon, ob die positiv sind oder nicht, ja? Also wie wie nah bin ich anderen Leuten? Und dann natürlich eben.
Über so einen zeitlichen Verlauf, ne? Wann ist denn was wann hat sich denn das Risiko für mich erhöht? Wann, wann hatte ich denn diese ganzen Kontakte, wenn ich da so eine Grafik sehen würde, wo mit so anschwellenden Linien, die mir ein Gefühl dafür gibt, so oh aha, okay, es passiert jetzt ein bisschen mehr
glaube ich, könnte so eine App eben auch dazu beitragen, Leuten so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, so
Leute, es wird jetzt langsam ein bisschen riskant, sowohl euer Verhalten als eben auch die Gesamtsituation.
Äh definitiv. Äh das ist glaube ich eben ja auch so eine Frage, wie stelle ich etwas dar, ähm die Leute oder viele Menschen öffnen die App jeden Tag und gucken sich das an und stellen fest, es tut sich gar nicht viel. Also da sieht man jetzt.
Steht da mal irgendwie ein niedriger Risikokontakt oder null oder was auch immer. Bei manchen kommt dann halt auch wirklich eine richtige Warnmeldung, ähm aber ähm ich glaube.
Dass man eben dieses mehr an Informationen einfach bieten kann, um auch die App attraktiver zu machen. Also nicht nur funktionaler, äh wie wir es gerade beschrieben haben, dass wir das, dass man einem hilft, das einzuordnen, wann das war, sondern auch ich sage jetzt mal.
Sie, sie wird sie, wie kann ich's beschreiben? Es ohne, dass es jetzt zu banal klingt, aber wenn die App besser aussieht.
Und auch mehr Spaß zu nutzen, dann spricht sich das auch mehr rum. Also das ist jetzt wirklich banal, das kann man auch kritisieren und so weiter. Ich weiß, aber leider funktioniert es ja so.
Also wenn wenn's irgendwie mehr Funktionalitäten mehr
und wenn ich nur irgendwas hin und her schieben kann und sehen kann, okay äh äh wie sich etwas Südom Graf, den du gerade beschrieben hast, wie sich sowas entwickelt und so. Das ist was, was die Leute dann schon auch eher triggert, zu sagen, hey, ich gucke dann doch nochmal häufiger rein oder
Ich zeige das meiner Freundin oder meinen Freunden, guckt mal an, was die App mir anzeigen kann. Dann sagt man ja, ah okay, dann vielleicht probiere ich sie doch mal aus. Ähm also,
Es ist sehr banal, ich weiß, aber leider äh ist es ja ich meine ganze soziale Netzwerke funktionieren damit, äh dass sie halt die Leute durch irgendwie so einen Quatsch
bei Laune halten, um's mal äh blöd zu sagen. Ähm und warum soll man sich diesen Effekt nicht auch zu zunutze machen, dass man bestimmte Sachen einfach auch ein bisschen besser darstellt.
Von den ganzen anderen Usability oder User Interface Problemen äh mal abgesehen, also
ich weiß nicht, ob's bei dir auch so ist, oder wenn ich die App starte und der macht gerade zu dem Zeitpunkt ähm äh den Abgleich äh mit dem Server. Dann steht da immer erst äh unbekannte Risikoermittlungen, weil das Ding, das die Datei runterlädt,
auswertet. Ähm und äh das hat immer für den Moment, denn anscheinend die App würde nicht funktionieren, dann wartet man aber zehn Sekunden und dann steht auf einmal da, okay, äh alles gut. Ähm das denke ich mir.
Sitzen da keine Leute, die einen User interface designen können ähm dass da sowas darf einfach nicht sein. Äh mein.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich so und ich meine hier wäre wahrscheinlich ähm also ich will dir das jetzt auch gar nicht so sehr zum Vorwurf machen, ja. Ich glaube,
Team, was sich darum gekümmert hat, äh ist zunächst einmal ein Team, was sich äh um die
Kernfunktionalität äh vor allem Sorgen gemacht hat. Und an der Stelle äh könnte man äh eben überlegen, ob's nicht mal ganz sinnvoll wäre, mal ein paar Gamedesigner mit reinzuholen. Also Leute, die wirklich Games machen, die auch, sagen wir mal, dieses ganze äh ich möchte deine Aufmerksamkeit haben und auch behalten.
Wunderbar kennen und es hilft gleich übertreiben zu wollen. Also ich denke da würde einiges gehen.
Um genau es geht ja jetzt bei dem Thema der Panemiebekämpfung vor allem darum, dass wir hier alle ein bisschen aufmerksam sind und dass wir jetzt vielleicht nicht die Maske vergessen, dass wir nicht vergessen Abstand zu halten und ähm das kann man ja auch über diese App
vermitteln. Man muss es auch alles ausschalten können und auch nicht nutzen müssen, wenn man das nicht will, das ist auch wichtig. Äh äh man darf den Leuten halt nicht auf die Nerven gehen. Ähm
aber ähm man muss es man muss ja eine gewisse Skalierbarkeit haben in einem Sinne von wie möchte ich die App denn nutzen? Die eine will es wirklich nur haben, dass man die Warnmeldung bekommt, wenn man einen Hochrisikokontakt hatte, gut und der,
Es gibt aber so viele, die jeden Tag die App öffnen und irgendwie ich das Gefühl habe, mir aber irgendwie mehr passiert ja hier nicht. Ähm.
Genau das ist natürlich auch.
Problem ist ja auch gar nicht nur auf die CWA beschränkt. Ich meine, es gibt ja auch noch sowas wie die Nina App, ja, die wahrscheinlich die wenigsten äh kennen. Mehr Leute haben vielleicht da mal sowas wie Cutwaren installiert,
eigentlich immer nur wenn schlechtes Wetter ist im Herbst so oha, der der Sturm kommt, wie sieht's denn äh aus, aber auch darüber trudeln ja ab und zu mal so Meldungen rein mit. Erhöhtes Risiko, Kowit und so weiter, klickt man drauf, sieht man irgendwie sein Bundesland ist irgendwie rot.
Ja, bitte hier mehr Informationen, dann wird irgend so eine schussellige Webseite aufgemacht, wo irgendwie äh acht Millionen Tonnen Text auf einen einprasseln und dann irgendwie überhaupt nichts sagen. Also das ist an der Stelle überhaupt nicht durchdacht
ähm vielleicht nochmal ein paar Vorschläge aus meiner
was hier ist. Meine, es wird am laufenden Meter über die aktuelle Institut derzeit berichtet, über die neuen Infektionszahlen. Wie viele Leute sind gestorben? Das muss ich mir alles aus den Medien holen. Indirekt, die irgendwie die Zeit
haben dieses PDF, was das RKI veröffentlicht irgendwie durchzulesen und dann äh wieder auf eine andere Webseite zu schreiben. Warum steht das nicht in der CWA
Warum kann ich nicht da einfach aufmachen und ich sehe sofort genau für meinen Bezirk oder den Bezirk, in dem ich mich gerade aufhalte. Okay, haben wir wieder das Problem mit der Location, ja? Aber kann man ja auch.
Manuell eingeben.
Ja, genau, ne? Also ich ich wohne da, zeigt mir mal das dafür an. Äh warum sind diese Zahlen nicht einfach da, ja? Warum warum kriege ich nicht eine eine Warnung von dieser äh Fahnenapp
Ja, wenn sie angestiegen sind so, ja, hier pass mal auf, dein Bezirk ist gerade viel los, Zahlen steigen
und so RWT ist bei, hast du nicht gesehen, äh mach mal ein bisschen vorsichtig. Das hätte sicherlich ein äh Effek.
Ja und das lässt sich ja super schnell implementieren. Also dieses Dashboard da reinzubringen, ist nun wirklich kein kein großes Problem. Ähm
dass das oder irgendwelche Informationen anzugeben. Ich sag mal, auch das hört sich banal an, aber wie lüfte ich eigentlich richtig? Äh wir haben ja alle im Frühjahr Gelände mit sich Händewäscht. Das haben wir alle gelernt jetzt äh
auch erwachsene Menschen haben jetzt gelernt, wenn man sich die Hände wäscht, aber.
Oder halten sich auch viele dran. Das ist ja auch schön, dass man das alle wissen, hoffentlich auch nach der Pandebie äh nutzen wir das auch weiter, wie man Hände wäscht. Aber genau mit dem Lüften, ja, es reicht eben nicht, äh auf Kippe zu stellen, sondern man muss Stoßlüften und so weiter.
Und das sind so Sachen, das könnte man alles in die App einbauen. Man könnte, man könnte so kleine Videos einbinden, ja oder was auch immer. Man könnte zum Beispiel auf das Thema
ähm A E Rosole habe ich jetzt gelernt, das heißt gar nicht Ero Sole, sondern A Ero Sohle
was bedeutet das eigentlich? Äh wie können sich sowas ausbreiten in in Räumen? Warum ist deswegen Lüftung gut? Warum ist es besser, sich draußen zu treffen
all diese Informationen könnte man schön mit kleinen Videos oder so darstellen, mit Animationen.
Und das macht man halt nicht, dass so viel Potenzial äh vergeben. Zwanzig Millionen haben sich die runtergeladen, die App, sechzehn Millionen oder so, öffnen sie vielleicht dann jeden Tag
Und da könnte man einfach mal mit einem Schlag äh sehr viele Menschen auch informieren und das macht jetzt zum Beispiel die irische App äh äh anders. Also die hat ja so ein bisschen
eben so eine Art Mini-Dashboard auch integriert.
In der in deren Corona App und ähm genau, das ist jetzt kein großes Problem. Man muss einen Punkt tatsächlich sagen bei der ganzen Frage der Location äh Sache, das geht sogar auch wirklich gar nicht, weil Apple und Google haben in ihren äh
erweiterten Vereinbarungen für die App Stores in dem Abschnitt ähm für dieses äh für diese Tracing Apps reingeschrieben, dass diese Apps, die auf dieses äh Exportion Motivication zugreifen, nicht auch gleichzeitig auf äh
Location Sachen zugreifen können und auch zum Beispiel nicht oft das Adressbuch zugreifen dürfen. Also man hat halt gesagt wer dieses Framework nutzen will
Der darf dann gleichzeitig dies und jenes nicht tun. Ähm, also deswegen wäre so eine GPS-Funktionität sowieso ausgeschlossen bei den äh Tracing Apps.
Ja derzeit, ja? Ich meine
natürlich etwas äh da kann man dann mit Apple und Google natürlich über äh drüber diskutieren, wenn solche Maßnahmen dann sinnvoll sind, aber wie gesagt, ne, also äh man kann ja den Ort auch auf eine andere Art und Weise angeben
ohne jetzt automatisch die äh GPS-Funktionalität zu benutzen. Was äh glaube ich die irische App auch äh besser macht, auch die Schweizer, die zeigen ja auch die Informationen zur Verbreitung der App an
Und das ist auch äh etwas, was in meinen Augen sträflich vermisst äh äh wird, weil ähm das ist schon
auch so ein Incentive, ja, dieses okay, wie wie viel haben wir denn? Wie viel haben wir denn dazu bekommen, wie viele benutzen sie denn jetzt auch tatsächlich wirk
gerade ist 'ne Information die sich ja auch auf Serverseite problemlos generieren lässt ohne irgendjemanden zu identifizieren und auch das wird nicht getan. Stattdessen gibt's irgendwie alle drei Tage oder manchmal auch nur alle zwei Wochen einen Tweet mit ja es haben immer wieder zwei Millionen Leute
App runtergeladen, es gab glaube ich einmal eine von der Telekom, wo sie mal wirklich
gesagt haben, hier so und so viele sind auch wirklich aktiv gerade sichtbar, da hatten wir, glaube ich, so das Verhältnis von neunzehn Millionen Downloads, zu vierzehn Millionen, die tatsächlich
aktiv sind, womit man halt schon mal so ein bisschen hochrechnen kann, wie so die Deaktivierungszahl ist, aber ich hab so den Eindruck hier ist auch so ein bisschen diese.
Wieder so ein bisschen so eine Angst ähm Fehler zuzugeben, ja? So oh unsere App wird ja gar nicht benutzt, das.
Das sollten wir gar nicht erst den Leuten sagen, um sie nicht zu demotivieren, aber dass das ja eigentlich genau den gegenteiligen Effekt hat, dass man, ne.
Du dran mitwirken kann, sie weiter zu verbreiten, wodurch sie ihren Nutzen steigert. Das wird glaube ich so nicht gesehen.
Genau, aber da sind wir wieder bei dem ersten Punkt äh mit diesem Spirit. Ähm ich glaube, was da versäumt wurde im im April, Mai Juni zu sagen, hey, wir wir nehmen jetzt mal hier drei, vier Leute, die setzen wir
in einen Raum, ja und die oder vielleicht nicht nur einen Raum aktuell, aber ähm die Sätze wird zumindest schon virtuell.
Genau, immer abwechselnd atmen. Ähm äh die, die äh sind jetzt nur dafür da, sich Gedanken darüber zu machen, äh wie man diese App weiterentwickelt. Äh oder was man einfach machen kann und die.
Dann würde man auch solche Ideen auch kommen. Also ich meine äh es kann ja nicht sein oder es ist ja schon ein bisschen schade, dass wir hier.
In diesem Podcast auf einem tollen Podcast alle das Sachen besprechen und die Frage ist ja und ich hab auch Gespräche mit Leuten.
Die würden das äh also es war immer unter der Hand, aber auch mit Leuten aus dem RKI und so gesprochen ähm wo es da einfach auch gar keine zeitlichen Kompetenzen dafür gibt, die sich wirklich dezidiert mit dieser App beschäftigen können, weil denen wurde das so ein bisschen auch ähm
Na ja, übergestülpt
es war jetzt nicht eine Sache, wo das RKI hurra geschrieben hat, äh dass sie äh äh jetzt diese App zu verantworten haben. Wenn man gleichzeitig nicht eben auch äh Personale zur Verfügung stellt und er sagt, okay, wir machen jetzt ein Team. Es wird ja jetzt gerade ein technischer Projektmanager für äh die App gesucht.
Also Gott sei Dank jetzt mal langsam. Ähm aber ähm,
Das hat natürlich gefehlt und dann würde man auf solche Sachen auch kommen. Wenn man sich natürlich auch noch gute Leute holt, also man muss natürlich, wie du gerade sagtest, vielleicht ein Game-Designer holt oder jemand, der sich einfach mit Apps auskennt und der weiß, was kann man äh eigentlich für ein gutes User hinter Facebook ähm.
Das wurde halt einfach nicht gemacht, das wurde versäumt und ja.
Kann man sich in an Irland ein Beispiel nehmen? Ich habe mir gerade mal die App nebenbei nochmal äh hochgeholt und stelle fest, dass sie irgendwie äh alle Boxen checken, die wir jetzt gerade aufgemacht haben, ne? Also sie sagen, wie viele Leute gerade die App äh benutzt haben heute. Sie sagen, wie viele Fälle es gibt, wie viel Tode es gab
an diesem Tag
eine schöne äh Bartschartgeschichte, was in den letzten zwei Wochen, zwei Monaten und insgesamt so passiert ist, wie die Zahlen steigen, aufgebrochen, wiederum nach jedem einzelnen äh County
bis hin zu wie viele Leute sind ins Krankenhaus eingewiesen worden, wie viel sind wieder rausgenommen worden und so weiter und so weiter Krankenhausauslastung bis hin zu sogar zur Testrat, also völlig geil. Und ähm all diese Informationen liegen im Prinzip vor, müssten halt einfach nur in so eine App reingechannelt werden. Vielleicht sollten wir es aber jetzt nicht so sehr äh daran,
beißen, weil es gibt ja noch ein paar andere äh Sachen, insbesondere hattet ihr ja ähm diesen Punkt Clustererkennung ähm.
Aufgemacht und das können sie mir vielleicht jetzt nochmal ein bisschen erklären was ähm da so deine Vorstellung ist oder eure Vorstellung war.
Was man hier nutzen sollte.
Also es gibt ja ähm als die App entwickelt wurde, ähm sowohl das Framework als auch die tatsächliche App dann äh hatte man ja noch ein bisschen andere wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse. Man wusste noch nicht so ganz genau, wie verbreitet sich das Virus eigentlich? Mittlerweile wissen wir ja, ähm dass äh es vor allem wenige Menschen sind, die
auf einen Schlag viele ähm.
Infizieren können. Und der Displaysitionsfaktor, also dieser Faktor K, der auch häufiger besprochen wird, ist der so, dass es tatsächlich.
Manchmal, also je nach unterschiedlicher Studienlage, ähm fünfzig, sechzig, siebzig Prozent gar an Menschen gibt, die niemanden infizieren. Dafür allerdings die restlichen dreißig Prozent
dafür sehr viele. Und ähm das ist ja in der App nicht betrachtet. In der App geht's ja eigentlich tatsächlich nur darum zu überlegen äh äh hatte ich mit einem Menschen
länger Kontaktaufnahmen, nahe Distanz. Ähm! Und äh! Das streat gar nicht die Rolle, wo ich mich getroffen habe, also jetzt
nicht die Frage wirklich GPS wo, sondern in was für einem Setting ich mich getroffen habe ähm das wird halt nicht betrachtet und das könnte man als Faktor hinzufügen und das ist das, was wir äh da vorgeschlagen haben. Ähm also zu erkennen
ob ich mich in einer Klasse Situation befinde. Ähm und das könnte man ganz einfach machen, indem man nur die
Corona Warn-App Signale oder die die Schlüssel der des des Frameworks zählt, also fange ich gerade in einem Moment nur einen Schlüssel auf oder zwei oder fange ich gerade,
zehn oder fünfzehn Schlüssel ein.
Zu einem Zeitpunkt. Ähm das könnte ich dann in der Risikobeurteilung, wenn ich das in der Vergangenheit mir anschaue, also ich sehe, okay, ich hatte hier einen Kontakt mit einer Person.
Die mittlerweile positiv getestet ist meine eigentliche Risikoberechnung würde sagen über eine klassische Risikoberechnung, ich würde eher ein niedriges Risiko sagen, weil wir vielleicht ein bisschen weiter weg waren. Ähm wenn ich aber jetzt nur in Bezug nehme, dass ich relativ viele
Schlüssel zu dem Zeitpunkt eingefangen habe, war das wäre das eine andere Situation, als wenn ich nur den Einzelschlüssel eingefangen hätte.
Das könnte sein, dass ich auf einer Parkbank gesessen habe und der andere auf einer anderen Parkbank äh auf der äh gegenüberliegenden Straßenseite keine Infektion.
Wahrscheinlichkeit. Ähm, wenn ich allerdings in auf 'ner Party gewesen wäre, kann's trotzdem sein, dass der Bluetooth
Empfang schlecht war, der Bluetooth ist ja auch eben kein genauer Abstandsmesser, das
war ja auch immer so ein bisschen irritierend im Frühjahr äh wie Leute gesagt haben, na ja, wir können ja schon relativ genau ermitteln, wie weit Leute voneinander entfernt sind. Das ist ja immer nur eine Aproximation, also eine Schätzung
weil es ja ganz verschiedene Störfaktoren gibt, habe ich dieses Handy in der Hosentasche, habe ich das vielleicht in einer, in einer Handtasche, wo noch ein Spiegel drin liegt.
Und andere Sachen, die das Signal abschwächen können. Ähm! Und wenn ich aber zu dem Zeitpunkt eben noch viele andere Corona Warn-App Signal oder.
X-Portion Notification Signale.
Empfangen habe, dann war ich in einer Klasse Situation und dann könnte ich sagen, dass ich das Risiko ein anders beurteile, dass ich dann sage, hm, na ja,
gehe jetzt einfach davon aus, das ist natürlich auch eine bissel eine Mutmaßung
dass ich hier zum Beispiel ein Setting hatte, wo wir viele Leute auf einem Haufen waren, wo man sich vielleicht auch viel bewegt hat, zusammen war, ähm dann auch nicht dauerhaft weit entfernt war, weil
eben diese Messung des Abstands ist ja nicht eine kontinuierliche Messung, es ist ja nicht eine, äh, dass ich jetzt jede Sekunde messe, okay, jetzt ist er acht Meter entfernt, neun Meter entfernt, sondern das sind ja immer Momentaufnahmen, die gemacht werden.
Am Grund dieser Zusammenkunft, dass ich viele Signale hab, würde ich das Risiko erhöhen. Äh weil ich mich in einer Klassesituation befunden habe.
Ich könnte, das haben wir auch nur als Diskussionsvorschlag gemacht.
Sogar einen Schritt weitergehen und sagen, ich fasse nicht nur die Corona Warnapp oder Notification, Exposé, Notification Signale auf, sondern generell alle Bluetooth-Signale, die um mich herum sind oder auch WLAN-Signale.
Und zähle die zusammen. Sie sollen natürlich nicht die Mackadressen gespeichert werden oder sonstige Sachen gespeichert werden, sondern einfach eine eine Zahl gespeichert werden. Also habe ich jetzt hier fünf Signale oder habe ich äh fünfzig Signale.
Ähm und diese Information einfach nur zu dem Zeitpunkt abzulegen, äh wie viel Sachen um mich herum sind und das ist jetzt.
Hat datenschutzrechtlich überhaupt kein äh kein keine keine Veränderung, kann dabei helfen, das Setting zu bestimmen ohne ein Eingriff auf sonstige,
datenschutzrechtliche Fragen reinzugehen, wie Location zu bestimmen äh äh oder sonstiges. Und deswegen haben wir das als Clustererkennung vorgeschlagen für die.
Vergangenheit, also in der Risikoberechnung und bei der Gegenwart haben wir einfach nochmal gesagt.
Man könnte dann, wenn also es ist eigentlich fast das Gleiche, es werden halt die Signale einfach nur ausgewertet, dann müsste auch das Framework helfen, das könnte die App gar nicht tun, aber ähm das Frama könnte man zum Beispiel erweitern, dass man sagt, okay, wenn ganz viele äh äh
Framework Signale in oder Schlüssel aktuell äh äh eingefangen werden, dann eine Warnmeldung anzuzeigen und zu sagen, hey, ähm wir haben das Gefühl, du befindest dich gerade in einer Menschenmenge.
Denkt doch bitte ans Lüften, tragt eine Maske oder was auch immer. Das könnten jetzt viele
auch dann ausschalten, weil sie es nervt, klar natürlich, das ist auch alles nur eine freiwillige Sache, aber wir kommen wieder darauf zurück auf das, was wir gerade besprochen haben
eine Aufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen, genauso wie das mit diesen Charts ist, die wir gerade besprochen haben, dass es ernst ist und ähm das kann in der aktuellen Lage dann
wenn man so 'ne klasse Situation eben ist auch nochmal dazu äh führen, dass man dann sagt oh ja Scheiße, ich steh jetzt hier
schon die ganze Zeit, es ist tatsächlich voll oder so ein Wochenmarkt können wir zum Beispiel auch nehmen, ne? Ähm, wo eben zum Beispiel in Berlin auch die Maskenpflicht eingeführt wurde für Wochenmärkte, wo es ja auch eben Situationen gibt. Es ist zwar draußen, das wissen wir. Es ist nicht so ein hohes Risiko
aber es kann in den Situationen helfen, wo wir den großen Menschenmenge ist zu sensibilisieren
Also das ist die Clustererkennung, einerseits in der Gegenwart, durch eine Warnmeldung, eine Infomeldung und in der Vergangenheit bei der Berechnung des Risikos.
Ja, ich meine, es ist wirklich diese ein, diese Einstellung wir kommen eigentlich immer wieder an diesen Punkt, so diese Einschätzung besser äh machen, ne. Ich habe ähm gerade mal in meiner Corona-Bahn-App geschaut, da steht halt auch so
Viel Begegnung mit niedrigem Risiko. Das heißt, in den letzten vierzehn Tagen bin ich irgendwie an Leuten vorbeigegangen, die sich positiv gemeldet haben. Mit der App, ja, also nicht alle, die überhaupt
positiv gemeldet worden sein, die tatsächlich Corona wäre an App verwendet haben und sich später dann auch noch über die Korona Warn App positiv gemeldet haben. Vier Leute in vierzehn Tagen und ganz ehrlich
Ich bin nicht viel unterwegs, ich gehe hier ab und zu mal im Supermarkt äh hier und da mal kurz äh irgendwo ein Paket abgeben.
Und das war's eigentlich im Wesentlichen, ja? Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo das herkommt und.
Nachbarn sein, ne?
Genau, also es
es fehlt einfach so ein bisschen dieses Gefühl für diese Aktivität und ich denke äh das stimmt schon. Man muss natürlich betonen, was du vorgeschlagen hast. Du hast ja im Prinzip schon angesprochen. Das sind dann wiederum Dinge, die man nicht mal eben in der App nachrüsten kann, sondern da muss man dann eben auch
'n Konsens suchen und mit Google und Apple sprechen und bin mir sicher da reden gerade viele auf die ein. Ähm.
An der Stelle wäre es natürlich auch sinnvoller da auf EU-Ebene sich erstmal auf irgendwas zu einigen und dann als EU vielleicht auch mit,
Apple und Google zu reden, aber das ist natürlich die äh selbe Problematik. Weiterer Punkt, den du ähm angesprochen hast.
Aber da, wir haben doch, wir haben doch vielleicht unseren Satz, also wir haben ja doch die zwei Player, die auf Augenhöhe mit Apple und Google sind.
Also ich meine ja, also ich meine, wenn wenn nicht die, wäre dann, ja, also wenn es äh also für irgendwas muss es ja gut sein. Also ähm ich frage, also
nochmal, weil ihr hattet das ja bei euch in eurer Folge, als ihr das schon mal besprochen habt, ein bisschen kritischer gesehen mit der ganzen Clustersache.
Kenne da jetzt erstmal keinen Nachteil drin. Es ist ja nur eine Frage, ähm äh man würde halt gegebenenfalls, wenn man sogar sagt, man erfasst sogar die ein oder anderen Bluetooth-und WLAN-Schlüssel, also in der Summe, also nicht die einzelnen
Schlüssel selbst die Mackadressen, sondern tatsächlich einfach nur hey gleichzeitig waren noch zu dem Zeitpunkt siebzehn Uhr dreizehn waren noch dreißig andere Signale da.
Ja? Ähm das ist einfach nur ein weiterer Messpunkt, äh den's gibt, den man in der Risikoberechnung reinbeziehen kann, der aber überhaupt nichts äh rück.
Ja, also ganz ehrlich, bin ein bisschen skeptisch, ne? Weil ich meine, wenn ich mal einen Bluetooth-Canner aufmache und mal so schaue, was ich da alles so sehe, ne? Also
Da sind viele Fernseher und und viele Dinge, die die nicht identifiziert werden können, permanent da. Also ich habe so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, dass man da viel draus äh
ableiten kann. Aber grundsätzlich gibt es sicherlich noch mehr Dinge, die man mit einbeziehen kann, ja? Also es wird jetzt zum Beispiel auch meine eigene Bewegung nicht unbedingt berücksichtigt. Gehe ich jetzt gerade, äh bewege ich
mich schnell oder befinde ich mich die ganze Zeit an einem Ort, das sind alles so Sachen
Die sicherlichen Framewalk äh auch noch mit auswerten könnte, inwiefern über so etwas äh bei Google oder Apple nachgedacht wird, können wir natürlich nur
kann man ja nur raten, um. Lass uns aber nochmal zum.
Weiteren Punkt kommt, den ihr angesprochen habt, dieses Kontakttagebuch, das ja äh gibt jetzt auch zahlreiche Initiativen irgendwelcher äh Developer, Einzelkämpfer, die jetzt so entsprechende Apps rausgebracht haben, um sozusagen zu verzeichnen, mit wem.
Habe ich denn überhaupt zusammengesessen.
Genau der Vorschlag äh an sich, der kam ja von äh Christian Drosten und hatte der im Beitrag geschrieben, äh auch bei der Zeit äh irgendwann im August, der der Beitrag hieß, äh der Plan für den Herbst oder ein Plan für den Herbst.
Da hatte er das vorgeschlagen und wir hatten halt also Lauterbach und ich überlegte na ja wie könnte das dann auch in der App tatsächlich umgesetzt werden? Wie gesagt
den Beitrag für die Zeit haben wir im August geschrieben, der ist also schon auch ein bisschen bisschen äh älter, also wir haben ja vor zwei Monaten geschrieben. Ähm.
Und ähm die Idee und da haben einige die Welloper sogar schon auch was vorgeleitet, das ist sogar auch richtig gut, teilweise ist ein bisschen sehr detailliert. Ich glaube, so detailliert muss es gar nicht sein, aber die Idee ist einfach, dass die Corona Warnapp
abends um zwanzig Uhr oder wann auch immer, man kann das einstellen, eine Pushmeldung schickt und fragt, hey ähm.
Du ähm möchtest du heute einen Kontakt äh Tagebucheintrag machen.
Man könnte sogar auch das wieder verknüpfen mit den Daten vorher, also habe ich heute viele Kurzschlüssel eingefangen, ja? Ähm dann war ich wahrscheinlich aktiv.
Man könnte sogar auch, du hast es gerade ja auch gesagt, den Bewegungssensor mit einbeziehen, also habe ich mich viel bewegt, denn also das ist ja auch.
Keine äh GPS-Information, sondern das ist ja der Bewegungssender, zum Beispiel beim iPhone zählt ja Schritte oder fahre ich Fahrrad äh oder gehe ich zu Fuß? Also ne das
wäre auch eine Sache, die man zum Beispiel bei der Klasseerkennung eben auch einbinden kann, diese Fragen. Aber ähm wir machen mal ein ganz naives Modell, um ganz einfach ohne diese ganzen Informationen,
was abends einfach anzeigt, hey ähm möchtest du einen Eintrag machen? Alles völlig freiwillig, niemand muss es tun. Ähm aber wenn ich das möchte, ist es im Endeffekt Notiz.
Ja? Also es ist jetzt nichts äh äh weltbewegendes, also das implementiert man äh mal eben am äh Freitagnachmittag ähm in die App. Ähm.
Es geht einfach darum, dass man in der App hinterlegen kann, einen Eintrag machen kann, hey, ich war heute mit äh dem und dem unterwegs ähm und ähm das notiere ich einfach mal und das habe ich dann innerhalb von zehn Sekunden gemacht.
Und schließ es wieder, das wird nur lokal gespeichert, äh von mir aus auch nach vierzehn Tagen oder drei Wochen auch gelöscht automatisch.
Und dann war's das. Es würde im Endeffekt aber nur helfen.
Dich selbst zu erinnern, äh wenn man äh tatsächlich positiv ist, ähm um Leute zu informieren oder das Gesundheitsamt weiterzusagen, äh mit wem man Kontakt hatte.
Damit das einfacher fällt, weil jeder weiß noch, was man gestern oder vorgestern gemacht hat, aber was man vielleicht.
Vor zehn Tagen gemacht hat, fällt dann schon ein bisschen schwieriger. Das ist eigentlich schon die gesamte Funktionalität. Natürlich kann man auch einfach einen Notizblock nehmen und natürlich kann man das auch in der Notiz-App reinschreiben oder eben eine von diesen Apps nehmen, die es da äh äh jetzt auch von anderen gibt
Nur wenn man schon so eine Corona Warn-App hat.
Und da kommen wir auch wieder hin zum Thema Aufmerksamkeit und Bewusstsein dafür sein und wenn jeden Abend 'ne Pushmeldung kommt, hey, möchtest du das eintragen
man kann sie auch ausschalten, ähm kann es dabei eben helfen, nochmal eine gewisse Awareness zu schaffen.
Dass eben Korona noch da ist. Ähm mehr ist es im Endeffekt auch nicht. Ähm.
Wie gesagt, wenn das jemand woanders eintragen will, ja bitte Go forit ähm und man muss es ja auch nicht nutzen. Es ist eher, mir auch nochmal eine Sache.
Ist dann auch ähm drauf hingewiesen, die App zu öffnen, weil es tatsächlich ja immer noch ein bisschen Probleme mit der Hintergrundaktualisierung geben kann, was ja nicht unbedingt ein Problem der App selbst ist, sondern eher bestimmter Betriebssysteme und auch Geräte und so weiter. Ähm.
Und dann hätte man automatisch auch jeden Abend, würde man die App öffnen, sie würde sich die Daten runterladen, das würde man auch sicherstellen. Ähm genau, das war die Idee.
Also so ein so eine minimale Kontakttagebuchfunktion da einzubauen ist jetzt sicherlich auch kein großes Ding. Also damit würde man äh nicht viel kaputt machen und.
Die Möglichkeit wäre da, ist natürlich bei solchen Sachen immer so ein bisschen die Schwierigkeit, das kennen wir ja auch alle von Leuten, die mal versucht haben, To-Do äh Apps zu benutzen und so. Also
man lässt das dann auch schnell wieder sein, wenn äh man nicht auf die richtige Art und Weise benachrichtigt. Ich glaub Wörter haben dann so separate Kontakttagebuch äh Apps noch größere Chancen, weil sie dann so Dinge erkennen können wie
du hast dich jetzt äh an einem Ort aufgehalten, der nicht dein Zuhause ist, den hast du jetzt verlassen, äh willst du dir da vielleicht was zu merken? Weißt du, so die Nummer. Ähm
äh das äh könnte dann nochmal äh extra sein, aber es schließt sich ja das eine schließt ja das andere auch nicht aus.
Nee, natürlich überhaupt nicht. Äh das das kann ja erweitert werden. Äh ich glaube, dass sie in der Karone waren, er wirklich sehr basic sein sollte, weil wir zum Beispiel eben über so Location-Sachen gar nicht rauf drauf zugreifen dürfen.
Wenn man die aktuellen Apple Google Richtlinien sieht oder vielleicht auch nicht sollte aus aus sag ich mal politischen Gründen oder auch aus Marketinggründen, weil man dann die Gefahr hätte wieder hier, hey ihr macht ja Locationzugriff und das will ich aber nicht
Und also solltest sehr basic sein, Push-Outification, man trägt's einfach ein und äh und auch nicht ähm und ähm.
Das ist eigentlich die der Grund äh äh Gedanke dafür, es tut keinem weh, aber es kann im Endeffekt helfen und es schafft halt wieder Awareness für das Ding.
Wir sollten vielleicht auch nochmal auf ein Feature hinweisen, was jetzt dazu gekommen ist, was aber keiner sieht, weil man das eben erst bekommt, wenn man ähm tatsächlich einen positiven Test hat.
Nehme dich äh es
gab ja jetzt eine Änderung der Parameter. Also vielleicht zur Erläuterung für Leute, die das nicht ganz auf dem Zeiger haben. In dem Moment, wo ich jetzt äh positiv getestet werde.
Und mir die App die Möglichkeit
bietet die Schlüssel zu versenden, wird so eine Annahme gemacht, nämlich eine Annahme, dass der Tag, wo ich das tue, auch mehr oder weniger der Tag ist, wo ich äh.
Ja infiziert wurde, aber es wird wurde bisher nicht so richtig gefragt,
wann denn der eigentliche Zeitpunkt war. Das heißt, diese Einschätzung war schon mal immer etwas verschoben und äh dazu kommt noch, dass äh grundsätzlich die vierzehn Tage
Schlüsselinformation, die dann rausgeschickt wird mit so einer nochmal mit so 'ner Risikokurve quasi überlagert wird, das heißt manche Tage werden dann als deutlich weniger infektiös angenommen als andere.
Und daraus bewertet sich am Ende eben das Risiko für andere, die dann eben mich als Kontakt auch tatsächlich hat.
Jetzt ist diese Kurve angepasst worden, ist alles ein bisschen nach früher geschoben worden und äh es werden jetzt auch Symptome äh erfragt beziehungsweise soweit ich das mit
kommen habe, wird auch erfragt, okay, wann fing denn das sozusagen bei dir an? Wann, ne, wann, wann, wann da äh kam das erste Mal, Husten oder was weiß ich, um eine Aussage darüber treffen zu können, okay, wie schwer hat's dich erwischt beziehungsweise.
Wann war vermutlich die Infektionszeit, ne? Was versprichst du dir davon? Hast du das überhaupt mitbekommen.
Ja, ich, also es es gibt ja, es gibt ja innerhalb des Frameworks und wie gesagt äh.
Ähm äh ja nur so einige Parameter. Es gibt äh ich muss es mir nochmal richtig angucken, damit ich ja auch nichts falsches sage. Ähm darauf, wo du jetzt gerade hin äh weißt, ist dieser Transmission Risk Parameter.
Ähm.
Und es gibt halt noch einmal die Signalstärke ähm äh des äh der Bluetooth ähm des Bluetooth-Abstandes oder beziehungsweise zwischen den Geräten äh die Dauer
Zeitpunkt und eben diesen Trends Mission Driss Parameter. Also es gibt vier Parameter, wodurch eine Risikoberechnung stattfindet.
Und die nationale App, also die Corona Warnap hat eben nur so wirklich Möglichkeit über diesen
letzten Parameter ein bisschen äh das anzupassen.
Und ähm aus dieser ganzen, aus diesem, aus diesen vier Faktoren wird dann halt eine Gesamtsumme äh berechnet.
Eins bis acht und ähm aushand diesen eins bis acht Werten wird dann ein ja eine Risikoeinstufung gemacht. Und was jetzt versucht wird ist halt eben den Transmission Riss Parameter ein bisschen anzupassen.
Mehr mit Symptomen auch zu belegen und abzuziehen und sage ich mal nicht nur so statisch zu machen und zu sagen hey wie du gerade sagtest es wird anhand der Tage, also wann war die Infektion und dann
nimmt quasi der Transmission Riss Parameter ab oder zu. Ähm
eingeschätzt, sondern eben, dass wir auch ein bisschen Abhänger von Symptomen zu machen und beziehungsweise von der eigenen Einstufung, wann so wirklich es wirklich losging, mit der mit dem mit der Infektion. Ähm
ich kann das natürlich jetzt nicht aus einer aus einer Virologensicht beurteilen, aber ich glaube natürlich, dass es schon hilft, äh das ein bisschen äh individueller zu machen
eben weil man ja auch nicht so viele Einstufungsmöglichkeiten.
Innerhalb der Risikoberechnung ist es glaube ich schon gut, wenn man das etwas äh individueller und spezieller macht und da sind natürlich mehr Informationen und mehr Angaben äh besser als äh wenn man das äh über den Daumen schätzt.
Was mir persönlich ähm noch äh fehlt, ist ja ähm die ganze Debatte.
Wo ist man denn eigentlich im Risiko, ja? Macht sich ja doch im Wesentlichen äh an einem Punkt, der krass fest, nämlich drinnen oder draußen.
Wir verhalten uns draußen alle anders und alle Erkenntnisse, die es glaube ich bisher gibt, weisen ja auch darauf hin, das Risiko sich draußen zu infizieren.
Extrem niedrig im Vergleich zum Innenraum. Also Faktor zwanzig ist so das letzte, was ich so ein bisschen rausgehört habe, das mag sich auch noch ändern und das mag natürlich auch immer von der jeweiligen Situation abhängen, aber das ist natürlich ein Faktor, finde ich, der in diese ganze Risikobewertung
irgendwie auch mit einfließen konnte. Und ich hatte hier schon mehrfach die äh diesen Gedanken gerollt
ob es denn nicht auch vielleicht angemessen wäre im Framework hier einen Weg zu finden zwischendrin und draußen zu unterscheiden.
Das ist natürlich jetzt erstmal nicht so einfach, weil man jetzt allein an der Location zum Beispiel das kaum festmachen kann, aber es gi
ja so ein Vektor, der vielleicht funktionieren könnte, würde mich mal interessieren, wie du das so siehst. Telefone haben alle äh so eine äh GPS, also eine Satellitennavigationsfunktion und die lebt ja davon, dass sie Satelliten sieht.
Und in dem Moment, wo man drin ist, sieht man halt nicht so viele Satelliten. Denkst du, dass es wäre eine Möglichkeit, dass man hier einen weiteren Parameter schafft.
Drinnen draußen und das Telefon selber entscheiden lässt, ob es meint, drinnen oder draußen zu sein.
Hm, da bin ich etwas äh kritisch, weil erstens haben wir dann wieder.
Thema mit dem auch nur überhaupt aufs GPS Modul zugreifen zu wollen. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie viel äh äh
das äh äh ziehen würde, wenn ich quasi permanent, also immer beschippt Abständen natürlich äh diese Funktion starten würde. Ähm.
Das müsste man sich mal genauer anschauen, aber ich glaube, man könnte vielleicht andere Parameter eher beziehen. Also, ich glaube, man könnte überlegen, äh ich habe hier gerade schon einen Bewegungssensor angesprochen, ähm habe ich da in diesem Vorfeld zum Beispiel.
Bewege ich mich also draußen, also bewege ich mich, nicht nur äh wenn ich mich bewege, bin ich meistens draußen.
Natürlich kann ich mich auch drinnen bewegen, aber meistens ist es ja so, wenn man sich drinnen trifft, setzt man sich hin. Ähm.
So. Ähm das ist also der erste Faktor. Der zweite Faktor, wenn man reinziehen kann, habe ich eine WLAN-Verbindung. Ähm.
Es ist meistens so, äh natürlich kann ich auch draußen WLAN haben, aber wenn man sich draußen irgendwo trifft, hat man's üblicherweise nicht ähm trennen.
Eher schon. Natürlich, wenn ich bei jetzt irgendwann zu Gast bin oder wenn ich im Café bin, verbinde ich mich nicht unbedingt mit dem WLAN, aber ähm es ist.
Eher drin als draußen, das heißt, das sind das sind eher so Faktoren, die ich vielleicht reinziehen würde, die auch nochmal
gar nicht erst das Thema äh äh Datenschutz wieder aufmachen würden, ähm weil ich da einfach nur ja Nein-Sachen machen würde, also habe ich WLAN, ja oder nein, ich brauche gar nicht speichern, was für eins.
Und bewege ich mich ja oder nein. Ähm und bei GPS, auch wenn du da nur fragen würdest, habe ich Satellitenzugriff
Würdest du immer wieder quasi diese ja GPS-Funktion ansteuern und ich hätte da einfach die Befürchtung
dass dass in der Thematik ein bisschen anders dann äh laufen würde und zweitens ähm würde ich mir da tatsächlich Sorgen machen, um äh die Batterieleistung.
Ja, bei der Dielastung ist sicherlich ein Faktor. Ich meine äh diese GPS-Funktionalität würde ja nicht von der App aufgerufen werden, sondern es ist ja sozusagen etwas, was dieses Framework intern vom Betriebssystem einfach abholt, sozusagen davon ausgehend, dass das Telefon das ohnehin
regelmäßig irgendwie tut. Kann natürlich sein, dass ihr das gar nicht so regelmäßig machen, wie ich das jetzt hier äh vermute, aber ähm.
Die Standortbestimmung ist schon etwas, was mehr oder weniger eine Dauerfunktion ist. Also viel hängt ja davon
verlasse ich meinen Ort. Äh da gibt's dann Kalenderbenachrichtigungen und so weiter. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass diese Telefone nur, wenn ich mal meine Map aufrufe,
wo bin ich denn eigentlich? Äh also auf jeden Fall denke ich mal, könnte man hier ein paar interessante Horistiken machen, auch genau das mit Bewegung zum Beispie.
Zu kombinieren oder HeimwLAN erkennen und so weiter, also äh allein schon die Unterscheidung bin ich zu Hause oder bin ich woanders, würde wahrscheinlich schon mal eine ganze Menge bringen, ne.
Ja
Ja, also es gibt, es gibt, es gibt ja so viele Sensoren in den Smartphones, die tatsächlich alle nicht genutzt werden und die meisten Sensoren sind ja eben nicht oder viele, nicht nicht alle, aber viele Sensoren
sind jetzt durch einfache Angaben eben jetzt nicht äh äh problematisch bezüglich des Datenschutzes, ja? Also ähm.
Habe ich eine WLAN-Verbindung, ja, nein, ähm ist jetzt, also wenn ich nur diese Information verwende, nicht welches, ist es jetzt erstmal ähm,
'ne Information wo ich sagen würde OK die könnte man eigentlich in die Risikoberechnung mit reinziehen. Wie stark man die dann gewichtet, das ist ja die nächste Frage, also gewichtig diese Informationen jetzt.
Mehr oder weniger
Das ist müsste man dann schauen, aber das wird ja jetzt gerade auch gemacht. Man hat ja erstmal nur überlegt, dass ein Transmission Rest Parameter, dass man äh äh den Zeitpunkt ähm
des Tests reinzieht oder beziehungsweise des Symptombeginns reinzieht. Jetzt hat man auch gesagt, durch die Symptomeinschätzung, hm, wir berechnen das nochmal neu, berechnen das ein bisschen anders. Und da könnte man sicherlich überlegen
Welche Faktoren zieht man da noch alle hinzu? Wenn es natürlich auch das Framework zulässt, das ist alles nicht immer eine Frage, was nur äh die App selbst machen kann. Das ist mir völlig klar. Ähm aber ähm.
Ja und das ist genau diese, das sind alles diese Punkte, worüber wir sprechen, das sind alles so Punkte, wo ich mir eigentlich wünschen würde, dass da Leute in, im, im Bunker sitzen und sich über sowas Gedanken machen und tatsächlich überlegen, wie kommen wir über den Tellerrand hinaus
mit Sachen, die wir eigentlich nutzen könnten, wo müssten wir Apple und Google ein bisschen pushen
was kann tatsächlich helfen ohne dass wir jetzt äh äh die die Grundintention der App stark verändern.
Eigentlich brauchen wir einen Riechsensor in diesem Telefon, ne? Das ist eigentlich eine Schande, dass das noch nicht gibt, wenn ich mir so anschaue, mit welcher Zuverlässigkeit Hunde mittlerweile in der Lage sind, infizierte Personen zu erkennen ähm.
Brauchen wir einfach Smartphones mit Riechsensorten und dann ist die ganze Pandemie sofort vorbei.
Ja, vielleicht gibt's ja irgendwann auch in drei Jahren auch äh äh die Smartphones mit integrierten äh Schnelltest Antigenschelltest. Wo man irgendwie ein bisschen Blut auf den auf den auf Touch-ID-Sensor macht und dann äh erkennt er, ob man, na ja, vielleicht man darf ja treuen.
Jetzt gibt's ja äh noch einen neuen äh Vorschlag aus der Gruppe von Leuten, die auch ganz maßgeblich an diesem DP drei Tandard ähm mitentwickelt haben, der letzten Endes die die Blaupause war für äh wie die Fremdworks dann funktionieren bei Apple und Google
äh der sogenannte Crowd-Notifier ähm hatte ich hier mit Pavel auch in der letzten Sendung schon mal besprochen. Ist ähm
quasi nochmal ein zusätzlicher Ansatz, der jetzt eine andere Denke verfolgt. Nämlich dieses explizite, ich befinde mich an einem Ort oder ich nehme an einem äh Event teil, ganz unabhängig von dieser unmittelbaren Nähe, was ja dann.
Auch diese Fälle abdecken würde, dass ich.
Mich an einem Ort befinde wo äh ich theoretisch den Virus über Ayursole einfangen kann ohne jetzt unbedingt einer infizierten Person unmittelbar über einen längeren Zeitraum nahegekommen zu sein.
Du hast jetzt auch nochmal auf diesen Entwurf drauf geschaut, ähm was ist so dein Eindruck.
Ich finde es gut. Ähm ich glaube, dass es natürlich vor allem auch ein Problem adressiert, ähm diese ähm
Zettellisten, die da in Restaurants ausliegt, also in den selbsten Fällen, ich meine, ich war jetzt im Sommer jetzt nicht so viel in Restaurants, meistens sage ich dann auch nur draußen oder eigentlich immer nur draußen. Ähm so richtig
gut funktioniert, hat's vielleicht irgendwie beim Drittel
entweder gab's Journalisten oder es wurde gar nicht abgefragt oder was auch immer. Ähm also deswegen ist es schon ein ein wichtiges Problem, was auch adressiert wird und wie kann man das so ähnlich wie die Korona Warnap lösen und nicht so lösen
dass es eben gar nicht personenbezogene Daten im Zweifel braucht oder beziehungsweise wie kann man die die Menge so reduzieren und.
Auch da transparenter, weil ich bin jetzt nicht der absolute Experte, was es betrifft, aber beim Durchlesen dieses Dokuments und bei dem mal Ansatz habe ich da schon viele Ähnlichkeiten
kennen können, also wie, wie man mit diesem,
wie man an diese Frage herangeht, nämlich auch mit einer Zweiteilung, äh so ähnlich wie es bei der Corona Warneb ist oder bei dem Trainwork ist, dass sich quasi eine zur Tagesschlüssel habe
Positivschlüssel und andererseits eben auch.
Kurzschüsseln, die ausgeteilt werden, also die Frage, was hinterlasse ich eigentlich in dem Restaurant und was muss denn der Restaurantbetreiber quasi freigeben, ähm wenn es tatsächlich eine Infektion äh äh dort vor Ort gab oder wenn jemand äh da war, der infiziert ist.
Also es spricht ein richtiges Problem an die Frage, die ich mir halt nur stelle, inwiefern kriegen wir das aus einem theoretischen Modell in eine praktische Umsetzung.
Und
Ja, da bin ich halt noch nicht so ein Bild, bin ich halt ein bisschen skeptisch, ob das klappt, ähm ob man da erstmal nochmal eine, äh, weil man jetzt wahrscheinlich immer drauf eher rekorieren würde und sagen, na, wir haben jetzt eine Lösung, die funktioniert mehr oder minder gut
Ähm ich glaube man muss, müsste das nochmal deutlich einfacher darunter brechen und dann dafür lobieren
dass äh so etwas auch umgesetzt wird und dann ist halt die Frage, wo baut man das dann ein? Wäre das auch eine Funktionalität der Chorona Warnapp? Wäre das äh eine Sache, die in einer separaten App ausgelagert lagert wird ähm und das sind halt so so Fragen, die es glaube ich äh irgendwie zu klären gibt, weil
ich glaube, dass es schwierig wird Leute ähm dafür zu bekommen
noch sich was weiteres runterzahlen, zu nutzen, das das glaub ich einfach wird ein bisschen schwierig und ich glaube davon hängt es dann im Endeffekt ab.
Ja gut, ich meine, das würde ja dafür sprechen, diese Funktionalität des sogenannten Presents Trackings auch durchaus noch mit in die CWA mit reinzubringen, weil am Ende ist ist ja auch das Ziel hier gewarnt zu werden
das dann sozusagen von zwei verschiedenen Apps machen zu lassen, da halte ich für Unsinn und diese Funktionalität, die hier mit dazu kommen würde
ist ja einerseits nichts, was in irgendeiner Form mit der anderen Funktionalität, also der anderen Funksalität widerspricht. Es führt im Zweifelsfall eher dazu, dass man eben
öfter die App startet, was ja auch etwas ist, was man sozusagen explizit.
Möchte und äh auch einen ganz anderen Nutzen darin sieht, ne? Weil es halt eben unter anderem einem äh vielleicht erspart sich in irgend so eine Liste einzutragen, ne? Weil na okay, ich registriere mich jetzt hier einfach mit der App, da kann man sehr viel schneller benachrichtigt werden. Ähm
ich denke, es gibt einfach auch sehr viele Fälle, wo dieses ganze äh Listen führen einfach.
Quatsch ist, weil grade so diese Restaurantsituation, da sammeln sich dann so lange Listen an, das ist einfach viel zu lange dauert, die alle äh abzu
lesen, einzutippen, nachzuverfolgen, bis da wirklich meine Warnung ausgesprochen wird, dauert einfach zu lange.
An der Stelle bin ich ja auch Optimisten, denke mir so, ja genau deswegen haben wir ja überhaupt diese Ansätze mit diesen Apps, um einfach einen schnellen Turnaround bei diesen Warnungen zu machen.
Um eben ein sich weiter ausbreitendes Infektionsgeschehen in einer Form frühzeitig mitteilen zu können.
Definitiv. Ich sage nur, ich ich bin halt deswegen ein bisschen skeptisch, also weil ich schon die Erwartungshaltung äh irgendwie habe, ne? Also wir wir diskutieren darüber, ob es irgendwie möglich ist, dass ein Kontak
Tagebuch in der einfache Notizfunktion äh in die Corona Warnapp implementiert wird und das ist anscheinend alles dauert
Dann sehe ich bei der Sache, auch wenn ich sie richtig gut finde, ähm aber eben auch nochmal so politische Komponenten drin hat, das müsste ja dann auch irgendwie in die Verordnung mit rein. Das müsste es regeln ja auch in die Bundesländer. Ähm.
Also, weißt du, was ich meine?
Ja ja klar und das RKI und so weiter. Das ist es ich meine dass die Politik an der Stelle langsam ist, ist ja jetzt auch keine Neuigkeit und in gewisser Hinsicht ist es ja manchmal auch eine Qualität der Politik
etwas langsamer zu sein, ja? Also diese diese Trägheit der Entscheidung kann sich ja auch sehr positiv auswirken, um nicht äh
zu schnell über zu reagieren. Hier äh
gab's sicherlich auch einige Entscheidungen, die äh vielleicht dadurch besser geworden sind, dass sie etwas länger gedauert haben. Trotz alledem würde man sich natürlich jetzt hier eine äh einen schnelleren Zyklus wünschen
man das ja wahrscheinlich auch immer tut.
Ja und äh genau, also deswegen, das möchte ich auch unterstützen, also auch bei der ganzen Kritik, die hier äh äh auch hier geübt habe und auch in der Frage, wie äh Projektmanagement war. Ich fand da einen Sternstunde eigentlich, auch wenn man dann sehr schnell gehandelt hat, war ja der April. Also als Diskussion gab, machen wir zentral versucht dezentral. Da war äh die.
Da war erst die Richtung klar, wir machen zentral und dann hat man ja eben auch äh Wissenschaftler haben ja einen offenen Brief, äh Wissenschaftlerinnen natürlich auch ähm einen Brief veröffentlich.
Wir haben halt diesen diesen Brief gemacht, äh, also D vierundsechzig, CTC ähm laut und noch weitere, die halt äh äh drauf hingewiesen haben. Und dann hat's ja ein Denkprozess gegeben und ähm das ist ja auch gut.
Aber tatsächlich
würde ich das, was ähm mit dem Crowd-Notify ja zum Beispiel hier äh äh vorgeschlagen ist, finde ich gut, aber da bräuchte man, glaube ich, erstmal wirklich ein richtiges Team vom RKI, dass sich mit dem Thema äh beschäftigt ähm und das dann auch
durchziehen will und dieser Spirit bekommt wieder zurück, der muss halt da sein, dass man sagt,
Jawohl, wir gehen jetzt hier richtig ran. Wir wir wollen jetzt hier auch ein bisschen was positiv nach vorne verändern und dann glaube ich könnte man das draufsetzen. Aktuell sehe ich, dass er.
Leider als äh Utopie.
Eine Pandemix, Spirit Task Force brauchen wir beim RKI. Ja, na ja klar, ich meine äh ist natürlich auch so ein Thema, sich dafür zu begeistern, aber ich denke sowas ähm wäre wahrscheinlich ganz.
Ist doch mega spannend. Also ich meine, ganz so schlimm wie
so schlimm wie die Pandemie ist, also die ist wirklich fürchterlich schlimm und ich hätte sie äh ich hätte mir das ja auch anders vorgestellt. Aber was will man denn machen? Also und das ist das äh äh was auch mein an, also wo ich immer denke, ich äh war auch dieses Jahr dieses Jahr so oft,
wirklich down, weil ich dachte, was eine Scheiße, ja? Und ähm! Aber es, es hilft ja nichts und jetzt muss ich doch irgendwie ein.
Kriegen, wo ich sage, okay, ich muss aus dieser beschissenen Situation das Beste machen, was ich habe und ähm jetzt haben wir hier was, eine Corona Warnap, die erstmal grundsätzlich gut funktioniert, das kann man ja sagen. Und jetzt lass uns doch mal ein Level weitergehen, lass uns doch mal
ich sag jetzt mal ganz platt, äh, dem Virus in Arsch treten, also weißt du, das fehlt mir so ein bisschen, dieses dieses Anpackende, das ich.
Irgendwie versuche einen Optimismus reinzukriegen und auch ähm.
Der Sache ranzugehen und äh und es nicht einfach zu verwalten und das ist halt so ein bisschen, was mich dann frustriert und äh ähm was nicht immer heißt, dass man jede Funktion einbauen muss, aber ich will erstmal, dass wir darüber reden und dass wir dann äh.
Erstreiten gemeinsam äh was dann die beste Lösung ist und wenn man über fünf,
Methoden oder Ideen spricht und wenn nur ein oder zwei davon eingebaut werden, ist es besser, als wenn man nichts macht. So sehe ich's.
In Deutschland muss man da eigentlich nochmal einen Verein für gründen, ne? Vielleicht brauchen wir so eine Art CWA äh User Group ja.
Aber man könnte, man könnte einen Hackstone machen. Also ich meine, der Hackestorn ist auch immer so ein bisschen ausgelutscht ohne Ende. Aber wenn man selbst nicht auf diese Ideen kommt, wenn man selbst jetzt nicht das Team dafür hat,
bei der Corona Warnapp um solche Fragen kümmert, dann muss man doch irgendwie organisieren, dass man sagt OK wenn jetzt Hackeson oder Barcamp oder whatever, mir egal.
Ein ein Idealsong sozusagen, ja? Also was was kann man machen, um das Ding weiter zu bewerben, da ein besseres Marketing zu machen? Klar und
ich denke, da sind auch schon genug Ideen im Raum, das zu bündeln ist sicherlich ganz sinnvoll. Wir fallen jetzt werden wir hier sprechen auch noch tausend Sachen ein, so, ne? Also abgesehen von so einfachen Sachen wie.
Wird nicht jeder laden verpflichtet, äh so einen Aufkleber an der Tür zu haben, wo äh die aktuellen Regeln wieder gegeben sind und nebenbei auch nochmal für die App geworben wird, ne? Oder warum
ist es so so schwierig überhaupt mal ein Ort zu finden, wo man sich testen lassen kann, warum kann einem die App nicht sagen, wo Testzentren sind, ja? Es gibt kein.
Klares Verzeichnis, wo man sich wie testen lassen kann. Also es gibt so viele Möglichkeiten, die man hier mit einbauen könnte ähm ja. Deswegen ist das wahrscheinlich.
Oder ein zentraler Ort, wo die Verordnung alle drinstehen, also würde man sagen, wo ich.
Weil wir sind denn die Regeln eigentlich gerade. Da muss ich halt auch äh tausend Mal äh äh wegklicken, bis bis da irgendwie Klarheit ist. Das stimmt. Das ist äh auch die aktuelle Verordnung äh ja.
Wenn schon Warnapp dann auch richtig bitte baden. Gut, wir sind uns eigentlich Herr Ding. Ähm.
Deine Zeit ist knapp, ähm aber ich denke wir haben ja auch äh alles behandelt, was sich hier eigentlich behandelt sehen äh wollte. Vielen Dank äh erstmal hier für deinen Beitrag.
Ja, vielen, vielen Dank, dass ich dabei sein durfte und dass ich äh ich habe ja in letzter Zeit sehr viel über ähm die Corona Warnap irgendwie auch so gesprochen, aber häufig nicht so im Detail oder so, äh genau, deswegen war das sehr, sehr schön, dass wir da mal äh
du mit deinen Ideen, ich, mit meinen Ideen, dass wir da mal gemeinsam ein bisschen Brainstormen konnten und vielleicht hört das ja einer äh in der Bundesregierung oder im RKI und fühlt sich inspiriert jetzt auch
nach vorne zu gehen.
Das war der Sinn. Genau, wir sind für den Ideas Hone sind wir auf jeden Fall zu haben und zur Not gründen wir auch noch eine User Group. Wie man das so macht in Deutschland. Alles klar, vielen Dank.
Und vielen Dank an alle fürs äh Zuhören hier bei UKW. Äh demnächst dann auch wieder mehr zahlen mit Pavel, heute erstmal äh dieses Thema. Ich sage.